winter is approaching in Europe and
Vladimir Putin's Russia is doing what it
can to make it an exceptionally
difficult one in Ukraine Russian forces
have been striking civilian
infrastructure including Water Supplies
power stations and residential buildings
Sometimes using so-called Kamikaze
drones
but the West is showing its medal with
EU plans to train some 15 000 Ukrainian
soldiers and NATO running nuclear drills
amid the tensions
today on to the point we ask as the war
in Ukraine escalates will NATO soon be
party to the conflict
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome I'm Claire Richardson
in Berlin it's a great privilege to be
hosting this edition of to the point we
have a fantastic panel for you this week
very pleased to welcome Marina henka a
security expert and professor of
international relations at the hearty
School in Berlin
Carolina Board member of the Polish
weekly Cultura liberalna
and Moritz gotman Chief reporter for the
German political magazine Cicero he
joins us after having just returned from
Ukraine
[Music]
thank you all so much for being here
Marina I'd actually like to start with
you President Vladimir zielinski has
said now that a full 30 of Ukrainian
power plants have come under Russian
strikes it's already leading to
blackouts across the country do you
think that the timing is intentional
with temperatures dropping in a cold
winter setting in
absolutely it's intentional but it's
also a result of what's happening in the
donbass and in the Curson region and the
ukrainians are advancing so there are
two Wars that are ongoing that's the
land war and that's in her son and
that's in the dawn pass and then there's
now this air war and actually the
ukrainians you know are doing quite well
in the land war and one of the responses
to the success to the Ukrainian success
is now the strikes on Western Ukraine
and you know targeting civilians and
trying to break the fighting will of the
Ukrainian people and Carolina is that
also your impression what do you make of
these attacks on civilian infrastructure
one should not be surprised I believe
because the strategy of Vladimir Putin
has been the same throughout all those
months and actually throughout all the
the past eight years so his basic
task his aim his goal is to create a
Soviet Union again is to create a
Russian Empire again and so he has to go
it's a process that started with
trichinya and then he went to Georgia
and of course he went to Ukraine so if
he cannot do it but just by saying I
would like to have this land and if the
ukrainians didn't say okay we just
surrender in three days then he will
destroy everything completely this is
now his um his means to achieve his goal
so you see this as the latest step in
Putin's plan uh Morris I want to come to
you How likely do you think it is that
these attacks on civilian infrastructure
are possible war crimes the United
Nations has said strikes on civilian
objects like power plants could qualify
well I would say so uh on the one hand
that's true that uh like uh hitting
power plants and so on it's clear
attacks against the civilian
infrastructure uh it's part of Putin's
plan to break the will of the ukrainians
on the other hand it's it's a positive
aspect like a small positive aspect that
this man that not uh many civilians were
killed during this uh huge these huge
strikes with 45 Rockets hitting Ukraine
all over the country there were only 20
casualties or so
but of course in the end it's an attack
on the civilian infrastructure and
Marina what do we know about Russia's
supply of artillery and weapons how long
do you think they can keep up these
kinds of attacks
so they're using now drones from Iran
right and it was widely interpreted as a
move
um because they're actually lacking the
missiles that they have been using and
so they're called Kamikaze drone they
have explosive loaded on them one of
them is just about 20 000
um US dollars so to a certain degree
it's much cheaper to use them and
destroy the infrastructure and Target
those civilian centers than using the
Rockets so that's indication that maybe
they're you know running low on on
missiles but overall I think you know we
should still count on the fact that you
know like they're Depots with a lot of
ammunition that they have from the old
Soviet days so it's dumb you know
weapons as they're called but they're
still there I would I would add that in
some ways also a sign of desperation of
putting these these huge Air Raids these
rocket attacks uh he tries to break the
will of the ukrainians because on the in
the land War uh Russia is losing for the
last six to eight weeks Russia is losing
every day several square kilometers of
land that it perceives already Russian
territory
psychological element there as well and
Maria you mentioned these Kamikaze
drones I want to see if we can actually
take a closer look at this new
development in the war
a live Chase in key police officers use
rifles to try and shoot down a so-called
Kamikaze drone from the sky Ukrainian
air defenses are usually powerless
against large-scale attacks
just like at the beginning of the war
people are wanting for their lives the
attacks are targeting people
but also a vital infrastructure
Shahed 136 is a so-called Kamikaze drone
from Iran but it carries up to 40
kilograms of explosives
although Iran denies selling it to
Russia Keith says that fragments of this
drone shot down in southern Ukraine had
both Iranian and Russian markings
this particular Iranian drone model
costs around 20 000 Euros each a
pittance compared to Russian missiles
our Iranian Kamikaze drones a game
changer for Putin's faltering war of
aggression
[Music]
let's dive into that Maureen I'd like to
put that question to you are they a game
changer I don't think so I actually
think you can't break the fighting bill
of ukrainians but what possibly can be
broken is the support of Western
countries because in the big picture of
things this is what Ukrainian military
prowess depends on and here you know a
lot of things are happening and we have
Congressional elections in the United
States and you have voices on the
Republican side questioning the support
the United States has provided to
Ukraine especially from California this
is Congressman McCarthy but also here in
Germany in Europe Energy prices are
rising and inflation is very high and so
I think you know Putin is counting on
the fact that maybe over the next three
four five months that you will have a
growing opposition in NATO countries and
then maybe also with a new Republican
majority in Congress and that will then
you know like possibly be a game changer
for Ukraine and Carolina what do you
think of that the will of the west of
NATO countries to continue to support
Ukraine throughout this war do you think
it will last through the winter the will
starts to be this Central notion of this
war right who has the will well I do
believe that it's true that you cannot
break the Willy of ukrainians because
they are the post-traumatic Society they
are extremely resilient this is very
typical for post-traumatic societies but
at the same time you can destroy them
completely you can destroy completely
the the country and this is what Putin
is is aiming at and as for the will of
the West well I don't think there is
only one will of the West I do think
that there is actually a conflict or a
very serious dispute within the West
about what is going to happen and I
think you have been very well pointing
at this there is at least a vast group
of people intellectuals politicians and
other actors who would like this and
this war to end as quickly as possible
because they would like to have the
business with huge as usual with Russia
and they would like to go back to the
economy as from before the war but there
is also this vast group of people I I
hope that this will prevail but who
knows the that believes that still
believes that this war is not about
Ukraine it's about the the west and the
the rules that liberal democracy the the
right to decide of a Nation uh which
direct Direction it is going to so we
have a lot of Wars here I'm all right I
do want to come back to you you
mentioned this psychological question uh
the Kamikaze drones that we just learned
about there uh one advantage that we
know they have is that they can strike
from long distances are giving
ukrainians the feeling that there's
nowhere safe anymore in the country do
you think that that is what Russia's aim
is with these weapons
uh that's true uh basically in in
Practical terms these Kamikaze drones uh
they can't destroy uh that much you know
they are not uh as as effective as the
big rockets that Russia was shooting at
uh Ukraine over the last month but uh
psychologically of course they are a
danger for the ukrainians because they
all have seen this uh over the last few
weeks they see the drones over their
heads and they know that somewhere they
will fall down
um so yes the the psychological effect
is the main one uh but uh actually this
only means that uh Ukraine needs more
um Protection Systems uh air air defense
systems yeah yeah because here's the
thing they slow they're actually quite
slow yeah they're called the moped of
the air and so if you have air defense
systems then you know you can shoot them
down fairly easily so it's not an
iskander rocket which is incredibly fast
and Incredibly powerful this is like you
know like this is the the the real the
good stuff you know that that Russia
also um has
important that we that we think about
this war as as if it was the covet right
we you can think that you have dealt
with a pandemic but then it takes
another phase and this is exactly what
is happening with this war so once we
think okay perhaps Russia is running out
of weapons then they use those and of
course they might be not as good as the
former ones but they are so effective in
killing civilians and and destroying
streets and buildings so I think it's a
it's a protein war from the the name of
the Greek of the Greek figure from the
Mythos that always change the shape
always change the the face and one thing
I want to mention about this war is that
despite the tensions uh NATO has also
held its annual nuclear drills I think
dozens of aircraft running training
flights over Belgium the North Sea and
Britain um let's see if we can take a
listen to what NATO Secretary General
Jen stoltenberg had to say on the
possible use of nuclear weapons in this
conflict
circumstances in which NATO might have
to use nuclear weapons or extremely
remote
Russia's nuclear retric is dangerous
Reckless and they know that if they use
nuclear weapon against
Ukraine it will have severe consequences
and they also know that a nuclear war
cannot be won and should never be fought
so NATO is insisting that these drills
are routine that they happen every year
and are not a direct response to
tensions with Russia but Marina I want
to come over to you and ask don't you
think that practicing using U.S nuclear
weapons in Europe is a provocation in
this climate
so it forms part and parcel of the logic
of deterrence of nuclear deterrence when
we look back in history
every single time the Soviet Union and
by the way the same goes also for other
nuclear Powers have used or threatened
um with nuclear weapons used in in kind
of an exercise scenario the opposing
party has done the same because the idea
of the turns is not oh you know like
they're threatening usage then we engage
in dialogue no the logic of the turns is
that signaling to them if you use them
on our territory then you will also get
destroyed
and so you know there has been a lot of
criticism on the NATO side that response
was lacking to all those threats from
the Russians using tactical nuclear
weapons and I think this has been
ramping up now from you know the United
States and from NATO first that Biden
and his National Security advisor have
come out and said
um if you use them you know you will
have devastating consequences and then
you know NATO is also now practicing and
this nuclear strikes but I think still
it's very important to underline that
this is not a novelty there have been
these tactical nuclear weapons stationed
on European soil since the 50s these
exercises are very regular and there's
just part and parcel of what NATO does
NATO is a nuclear Alliance and words do
you think the West's response to these
threats of using nuclear weapons has the
response been adequate
I would certainly say so uh basically
it's uh an answer to Russia's threats
and uh president zielinski of Ukraine he
was really pushing for this kind of
answer because uh Ukraine itself if
there will be a nuclear
um uh hit the Nuclear Strike then
Ukraine will be the victim so zelenski
was telling the West that please make
clear to Russia with clear actions that
they shouldn't do this because
afterwards it will be harder you need
these signals like this maneuver you
need these signals beforehand before it
happened okay so the Maneuvers are an
important part of that Carolina do you
think that Putin would risk a nuclear
war with NATO I know that in your home
country Holland also obviously in the
Baltic states there does seem to be a
sense that there is a real fear of
exactly that happening in Poland and in
the Baltic states basically people don't
have as big fear of the nuclear conflict
as for example here in Germany that's
very interesting I wouldn't like to be
misunderstood here it's not that we are
so naive and think that nuclear weapons
are not uh horrible they are horrible
they destroy everything but the
experience of the states Eastern to
Germany is basically that we have
experienced a cyclical destruction
coming from the Russian Empire for the
past 300 years which makes us think okay
nuclear weapons are horrible but at the
same time they are
one only one of the ways you can totally
distract a country so this is the
totally destroy the country so this is
very important I think and if you ask me
whether I think a Putin is going to go
into into nuclear war well I would say
yes and no the possibility the
probability that he will use the nuclear
weapons I think is quite high but I
don't mean that he is going to strike
very hard on a city for example it won't
be another Hiroshima it might happen on
the sea it might happen very high in the
air so that the systems go down so that
he shows that his strength and his
ability and then it all makes the NATO's
answer quite unclear
it makes it more difficult so I don't
think you know using the same language
like Chernobyl or Hiroshima or nuclear
war I don't think this really explains
the nuanced character of what might
happen Okay so that's not a helpful way
of describing it Marina what's the view
here in Germany toward the possible use
of nuclear weapons so I'm a professor I
do a lot of research on this question
interestingly I ran a survey in 3 000
Germans answered and so first and
foremost they're actually also get angry
so they're not that scared I was myself
surprised by those results but more
people in Germany get angry by such a
scenario than actually scared in the
sense they get angry at Vladimir Putin
for engaging in this exactly and then
you know like the the largest number of
respondents is in favor of a
conventional strike to respond to such a
tactical nuclear weapon strike so I
think this idea that Putin has that he
can intimidate and paralyze NATO and
especially Germany I totally concur with
Carolina is wrong so probably you know
like there will be much more kind of an
angry movement that says like now we
really cannot trust this guy and we have
to you know like support Ukraine even
even more and more do you think that
that public opinion that Marina is
talking about is also shared by
politicians in Germany that if we were
to see a nuclear strike that the correct
response would be one using conventional
Warfare from the West
well as you have pointed out uh there
may be a tactical Nuclear Strike that is
not so clear to to judge you know in the
air uh on the sea so uh they if
something like this happens there will
be a discussion on what was this uh
should we answer full scale on this or
not because uh there are not so many
victims maybe it was only technical
damage Maybe
so uh do you think there will be a
discussion or it won't be an it won't be
an immediate response then
uh I think there will be a discussion
because in the end this
in the end Ukraine
today is not a NATO member state
so if Putin attacked a NATO member said
the answer would be clear and immediate
but of course in the case of Ukraine
there is maneuver for discussion all
right well meanwhile the European Union
is currently planning a mission to train
some 15 000 Ukrainian soldiers in its
member State we've mentioned that before
the word in EU circles is that the
German bundeslaire will take on up to 5
000 of them but British forces have
already been training Ukrainian soldiers
since this summer let's see if we can
take a closer look
[Music]
a battle for every house but there is no
gunfire here yet Ukrainian soldiers are
practicing house to house combat under
the most realistic conditions possible
at a training facility in the United
Kingdom
this provides the soldiers with an
opportunity to practice and perfect
techniques that have long been part of
Ukrainian Warfare training programs like
this will soon be rolled out in the EU
as well
EU foreign ministers at a meeting in
Luxembourg are discussing plans that
include training programs for some 15
000 Ukrainian soldiers
and several EU countries have already
honored national agreements to train
Ukrainian soldiers
Germany's most recent commitment has
been in the areas of air defense and
artillery
the eu's mission is scheduled to run for
two years initially for example to train
snipers and develop their skills in
areas like first aid
and mine clearance
[Music]
but how sustainable is it to train
Ukrainian soldiers without delivering
more sorely needed major weapons
that is the question well as we've heard
NATO and the EU are supporting Ukrainian
uh Ukraine with financial support modern
weapons now also training soldiers on a
large scale Carolina do not think that
that therefore de facto makes the West a
combatant in this conflict West has been
the combatant of this war from the very
beginning from day one of this war
because there is no one war there are
two Wars at least one one war is the the
the the war with weapons in Ukraine and
the other is about the the European
values and liberal democracy and the
right to decide about your country so as
for the second war we were on this war
from the very beginning as for the first
war the the military war I think we that
escalation is unpreventable we are
stepping into the war and you cannot
prevent it it is escalating that is a
harrowing prediction Morris is it one
that you share
well it actually depends uh on Putin
what will happen further because uh of
course this mobilization that we saw
over the last two months uh it points
out that Putin wants to continue this
war he's not ready to negotiate at the
moment but this may change as we see the
the situation on the front line where
the ukrainians are pushing the Russians
out of their territories so yeah it
basically depends on how Putin will act
in the upcoming months and to the
question of whether NATO is a party to
this conflict already what do you think
uh the west or the NATO is de facto uh
part of this conflict already
the Euro uh it's not because we don't
have any NATO troops fighting in Ukraine
any NATO troops fighting against Russia
and I think uh
yeah this this is an important aspect
this is also important for our public
discussion that's why German Chancellor
Schultz will always say that we are not
uh part of this war but
de facto we are
uh now Marina I want to ask you about
the implications of Russia has in the
territories that it's claimed that it
has annexed in the Harrison region it
has imposed martial law do you think
that this adds a piece to the puzzle
that will turn the direction of the war
in One Direction or another
no it just uh shows that um you know
Russia is trying to play all the means
possible right so like in these
territories Russia can basically do
whatever it wants all the laws that have
been prevailing there are basically
suspended there can be curb use that can
be incarcerations with any need to
justify it
um and you know I think to this question
of you know whether we're already at War
and yes and because we need to also ask
what are we fighting for and what is
this war all about and I think Carlia
and both Moritz mentioned it quite
nicely this is not just a war over
Ukrainian territory this is a war about
democracy this is more about our liberal
value system this is the war about our
liberal World Order and I'm willing to
defend it and I think we need to defend
this this is in the end what the fight
is about and I think you know we should
not be ashamed saying we are part of
that war because we benefit from
democracy and from this liberal value
system every single day here in Germany
and so I think you know and we need to
you know pick pick up the slack and save
you're fully supporting also Ukraine
because they are fighting it for real
and by the way we are also benefiting
from the fact that it's not possible to
change borders
especially in Europe where we know from
our history that Wars basically also
always began because of this because one
state wanted to have chunks of another
state and that's where the wars began I
think it's quite paradoxical and ironic
that the only citizens of Europe that
are capable of giving their lives to the
European Union are actually ukrainians
that's interesting Marina you mentioned
that you were willing to defend this do
you think there's consensus in western
states that they are also willing to
make the sacrifices needed to see this
through to the end in supporting Ukraine
very interesting polls have come out by
yougov and actually across all NATO
states there is still majority
supporting it but there are three
exceptions that's Italy that's Greece
and that's Hungary only in those three
countries and of the of NATO outside of
the NATO context is a different question
that we have India you have Indonesia a
lot of other countries being very
skeptical
um of what what NATO does and what the
United States does in in Ukraine but you
know I think that is still the support
all right I think we're going to leave
it there that's all the time that we
have for this episode of to the point I
want to say a very heartfelt thanks to
all of our wonderful guests for joining
me today a thank you to our team working
behind the scenes and all of you
watching from home for your time if you
are watching us on YouTube and you have
any comments about this show I would
love to hear them please do share them
below take care and bye for now
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign